[Musique]
bonjour à tous nos amis à poil et à
plumes c'est Miss plumes et nous vous
souhaitons la bienvenue dans ce
cinquième épisode de kek et fait la
bestiole aujourd'hui ce sera un oiseau
d'eau qui retiendra notre attention
grâce à son balai aquatique très
particulier cet oiseau s'appelle un
falarop et il vit principalement en
Amérique du Nord pour les petits
nouveaux sur la chaîne je vais vous
présenter une vidéo d'oiseaux le but du
jeu est de trouver pourquoi l'oiseau
agit de la sorte si vous n'en savez rien
pas de panique il y aura un quiz qui
vous permettra de choisir entre 4
réponses à vous de trouver la bonne vous
êtes prêt c'est parti
alors des idées si vous n'en avez pas
voici 4 propositions seule l'une d'entre
elles est valide si vous voulez jouer
entrez la réponse que vous avez choisi
en commentaire alors cliquez fait la
bestiole
petite a c'est la saison des amours
comme les flamants roses tous les mâles
répètent ensemble leur danse de groupe
pour attirer ses dames petit B ce sont
des oiseaux très territoriaux et leur
habitat est de plus en plus réduit du
fait de la progression des villes il
défendent donc chacun leur toute petite
partie du lac contre leur concurrents
petit C c'est une technique de pêche
secrète en tournant les aliments chacun
un vortex miniature pour capturer et
faire remonter les petits invertébrés
dont il se nourrissent
petite idée il répète une version très
vitaminée du Lac des Cygnes
déjà trouvé la bonne réponse ou bien
encore en train de réfléchir pas de
souci je vous remets la vidéo pour que
vous ayez le temps de délibérer
profitez-en pour bien observer tous les
petits détails qui pourraient vous
mettre sur la voie allez à tout de suite
et nous revoilà devant ce quiz pas si
simple aujourd'hui il faut bien le dire
alors qui est fait la bestiole la bonne
réponse était la réponse
c'est la technique de pêche très
singulière du fallarop de Wilson ce
Falla rope tournoi sans cesse sur une
toute petite zone soulevant avec ses
pattes lavase du fond du lac et
provoquant la création d'un petit vortex
qui fait remonter les minuscules
invertébrés du fond de l'eau vers la
surface oui oui cet oiseau pêche avec
des temps Natsu marine même sans
connaître l'espèce on pouvait deviner le
but de ces ronds dans l'eau en observant
la tête des oiseaux il plonge
régulièrement le bec dans l'eau pour
attraper les crustacés qui remontent à
la surface c'est donc qu'ils sont en
train de s'alimenter le phalaro de
Wilson n'est pas un oiseau commun par
chez nous même s'il lui arrive de
s'échouer sur nos plages il reste
habituellement confiné au continent
américain c'est un oiseau un peu
particulier car contrairement aux autres
oiseaux d'eau chez le falarop de Wilson
ce sont les femelles qui sont les plus
grosses et les plus colorées pas les
mâles
ce sont aussi elles qui courtisent les
mâles lors de la saison de reproduction
et pour couronner le tout elle ne
s'occupe même pas de leur zone ni de
leur petit choisissant de les laisser au
bon soin du mal d'ailleurs c'est une
espèce dite polyandrique où chaque
femelle se reproduit avec plusieurs
mâles lors de la saison de reproduction
la femelle séduit un premier mâle avec
qui elle pond 4 une fois ces œufs pondus
elle abandonne le mal et par la
recherche d'un autre reproducteur avec
lequel s'accouplait de nouveau elle pond
4 œufs avec ce second mâle puis repart
en quête d'un troisième mâle avec qui
elle pondra à nouveau 4 œufs et ainsi de
suite le mâle couvre les œufs tout seul
et s'occupera lui-même d'élever les
poussins qui fort heureusement pour lui
quand même son il diffuse et donc savent
se nourrir tout seul dès la naissance un
peu comme des canetons par exemple
une fois la saison de reproduction est
terminée les oiseaux s'envolent vers
l'Amérique du Sud pour hiverner au
soleil et ne reviendront dans le nord
qu'au printemps suivant durant ce long
voyage il progresseront par étape
profitant des Grands Lacs
nord-américains pour manger tous leurs
comptants et gagner l'énergie nécessaire
à la migration leur technique de pêche
et d'ailleurs tellement efficace qu'il
double souvent leur poids rien qu'en
mangeant qu'il arrive même que certains
oiseaux ayant trop mangé soit carrément
incapable de décoller au moment de
continuer la migration ce qui permet aux
scientifiques qui les étudie de s'en
saisir sans difficulté l'oiseau étant
tout bonnement cloué au sol pour cause
de surpoids
et voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
bonne journée à vous et à très bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures avec des
plumes
[Musique]